- No matter what you
think of Michael Cohen,
he can wear a suit coat.
He's got that going
for him, which is nice.
Michael Cohen would make a
great, great movie character.
In fact, his life often seems
more like fiction than fact.
That Cohen could hold
the key to how much legal
and political trouble his estranged,
one-time, boss Donald Trump
is in, feels somehow fated,
written in the stars as
though this is the only way
the story of the The Donald
and Michael could end.
Now that story begins
in the most New York City way
possible, a condo board fight.
Starting in 2001, Cohen
owned a condominium
in Trump World Tower,
a building near the United
Nations in the Big Apple.
Cohen convinced his parents, his in-laws
and a business partner to also
buy condos in that building.
Cohen got himself on the
condo board at the building
and, in a fight between Trump
and some of the tenants,
Cohen took Trump's side.
Don't act surprised.
So Trump said, who is this guy?
My lawyers that I give
thousands of dollars to
couldn't do it.
I'd like to meet him.
Cohen's uncle, Dr. Morton Levine,
told the Associated Press.
So, the two men met.
Cohen, who had read The Art of
The Deal not once but twice,
clearly impressed Trump.
And the rest is history.
Of that moment, Trump
recently told Fox News this.
Years ago, many years,
like 12, 13 years ago,
he did me a favor.
He was on a committee, and he
was so responsive and so good,
and I said, he's a nice guy.
Now, Trump hired Cohen
to work as a sort of jack of all trades
for The Trump Organization,
but really to work for him, in 2006.
And Cohen has been described
as many things to Trump,
personal lawyer, fixer,
confidante, intimidator,
and some things I just
can't say even on YouTube.
And here's how Cohen
himself described his job
in an interview with ABC News in 2011.
Quote, if somebody does
something Mr. Trump doesn't like,
I do everything in my power
to resolve it to Mr. Trump's benefit.
If you do something wrong,
I'm going to come at you,
grab you by the neck,
and I'm not going to let
you go until I'm finished.
Gee, sounds kind of ominous, right?
That was the point.
Over the decade between 2006 and 2016,
Cohen repeatedly distinguished himself
and won Trump's ongoing
loyalty by being willing to say
and do things for Mr.
Trump, as Cohen relentlessly
referred to the billionaire,
that no one else would do.
He was the most loyal guy,
the guy who would always
have Trump's back,
whether on a business deal
for some new golf property,
or in yelling at a magazine editor
for not including Donald Trump on a list
of the 200 most influential New Yorkers,
which of course actually happened.
Now that loyalty paid off
(cash register dings),
literally, for Cohen.
He shopped his connection to
Trump around wherever he went.
Now, some of it was innocuous,
if sort of pathetic.
One woman told the Washington Post
that she ran into Cohen at
their kids' baseball game,
and that Cohen whipped out his phone
to show her pictures of Trump
at his son's bar mitzvah.
Quote, he was very proud,
she told the Post of Cohen.
I'll bet.
But Cohen was doing a lot more
than just showing off his
kid with a famous guy.
Over the decade he worked with Trump,
he played off his
closest-to the billionaire
real estate mogul to feather
his own nest repeatedly,
through his law practice
using his work for Trump
as a trump card for perspective clients.
He amassed a fortune in taxi medallions,
the little medals required
to own a cab in the city.
He invested in an offshore
gambling operation
near Miami, which failed.
In short, Cohen became
a mini version of Trump,
with the successes and the failures,
a wheeler-dealer who fixed problems
for a bigger wheeler-dealer.
By the time Trump started
running for president in 2016,
Cohen was alternately described
as the sixth Trump child,
Trump's Tom Hagen, it's
a Godfather reference
for those of you under 30,
or Trump's Michael Clayton,
a deeply underrated movie.
Then, it all went wrong as
it always, always goes wrong.
I told you, this was like
a particularly juicy novel.
In the course of the 2016 campaign,
Cohen orchestrated hush
money payments to two women,
porn star, Stormy Daniels,
and Playboy model, Karen McDougal,
who alleged they had affairs with Trump
during the mid-2000s.
Trump denies those affairs.
Now, questioned about
the source of the money
for the six-figure payment to Daniels
in exchange for her silence, Cohen lied,
said it was his own money
and that Trump never knew
anything about any payments.
Now that was just one of the many lies
Cohen now admits to telling.
Another biggie, how about
when he told Congress
he had cut off all
conversations with the Russians
about a Trump Tower Moscow development
way back in January, 2016.
Turns out, as Cohen later admitted,
those conversations were
ongoing through June, 2016.
Now Cohen said he lied about the timing
of the Russian conversations
because he was worried
telling the truth might
hurt Trump's chances
of winning the White House.
Now everything changes for Cohen and Trump
on April 9, 2018.
That's the day the FBI raids Cohen's home,
office and hotel room.
Sidebar, what normal person has a house
and a hotel room in the same city?
Hunh, the feds seized
thousands of documents,
emails and other notes on Cohen's
various business dealings,
both for Trump and for
himself, in that raid.
Now, Cohen initially
denied any wrongdoing.
Trump called the raid, quote,
an attack on our country.
But it slowly but surely became clear
that Cohen's long-time,
unflinching loyalty to Trump
was eroding badly.
By late August, 2018, he had cut a deal,
pleading guilty on eight criminal counts
and agreed to cooperate
with the ongoing probe
surrounding Trump's 2016 campaign.
And Cohen also dropped this bombshell.
He said he coordinated the
payments to Daniels and McDougal
at the direction of Trump who, Cohen said,
coordinated the whole thing,
which made the President
of the United States,
in Cohen's version of events at least,
an unindicted coconspirator
in a plot to end-run campaign
finance law to preserve
and better his chances of
winning the White House.
Yeah.
Trump denies everything, of course.
- Michael Cohen is lying,
and he's trying to get a reduced sentence
for things that have
nothing to do with me.
- Quote, I never directed
Michael Cohen to break the law.
He was a lawyer, and he is
supposed to know the law,
Trump tweeted in December, 2018.
And, Trump later told Fox
News that the prosecutors,
quote, put those two charges
on to embarrass me, end quote.
But, before Cohen heads to jail in May
to serve a three-year
sentence for his crimes,
he'll get a chance to
tell his story to Congress
and the public, who will
most definitely be watching.
For a man who famously
pledged he'd take a bullet
for Trump, Michael Cohen
could now be the one
who bangs a final nail into
Trump's political coffin.
And that is The Po!nt.
We make episodes twice a week,
so make sure to check back
every Tuesday and Thursday for
brand new political content.